y estos manifestantes creen que la
propuesta supondría el fin del objetivo
de cero emisiones para 2050 de la unión
europea el bloque está en camino de
poner una etiqueta verde a los proyectos
de inversión de gas y energía nuclear
que son contaminantes en un intento por
ayudar a sus miembros a hacer la
transición a una energía más limpia lo
que la comisión propone hacer es
etiquetar esas energías sucias como
verdes y al hacerlo podría canalizar
miles de millones de euros de
financiación lejos de las renovables y
hacia proyectos climáticos sucios en
europa el resto del mundo está mirando
lo que hacemos aquí y europa tiene la
oportunidad de establecer un estándar
mundial la etiqueta vendría acompañado
de condiciones como la promesa de pasar
al cien por cien de energía baja en
carbono para 2030 y cinco estados del
bloque como austria y países bajos se
han pronunciado en contra de la
propuesta mientras que el director del
banco europeo de inversiones advirtió
que las etiquetas podrían desanimar a
los inversores verdes la unión europea
lleva más de un año luchando por llegar
a un acuerdo en torno a las diferentes
dependencias energéticas de sus estados
miembros algunos como francia dependen
en gran medida de la energía nuclear que
tienen bajas emisiones de carbono una
vez instalada otros como alemania creen
que la energía nuclear es insegura y
dependen del gas ruso que según dicen
podría ayudar a la transición de países
dependientes del carbón como polonia